Nikita starts off this hour in Richmond
Virginia hi Nikita welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
good afternoon sir so nice to meet you
how are you better than I deserve how
can I help a little bit of background so
my parents went through Financial Peace
University and I stumbled across their
book from that class about two weeks ago
and started listening to your show as a
result I am in baby step two I do have
quite a bit of student loan debt a car
loan and about $6,000 remaining in
credit cards I would like to buy a house
in the next three to five years knowing
all of that my question is should I
close credit cards that carry a zero
balance even though they've been open
for seven to ten years and how does that
affect my credit for knowing that I'd
like to buy a house at some point okay
we're gonna recommend your debt free and
that you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and you save
your down payment to buy a house okay
okay so how much do you owe how much you
owe on your car
$9,000 what do you owe on your student
loans two hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars okay you a doctor or a
lawyer okay cool how long you been out
about five years okay what are you
making seventy one thousand after five
years yes sir I work for the government
okay well let's just go ahead and try it
out on the uncomfortable land land of
uncomfortable you have two hundred
thirty two thousand dollars you need to
not work for the government okay okay
you have the potential to make twice
what you're making in your sleep okay
don't you yes yeah yes she did have
behind working for the government was
that they would forgive the loan after
ten years
about three years into that yeah so for
seven years we're not gonna buy a house
because we're gonna limp along yeah I
would just change careers and get out of
debt in like two years I won't be - I
wouldn't be to be three but you'd be
dead free in three years and you know
yeah you know that's so let me kind of
let me just back up for a second for
other people that are listening not just
for you but here's the decision-making
paradigm that this ten-year debt
Forgiveness causes people to mess up on
I'm just gonna talk about it right in
front of you Nikita okay
yeah the ability to make $150,000 a year
you're making 70 so that's $80,000 loss
so that you can get debt forgiveness for
ten years that's eight hundred thousand
dollars you paid to pay off this 232,000
you see how I never thought of it that
way yeah that's what government
subsidized crap causes people to do that
part of our brain dies when we sign up
for this and so that that's what I'm
that's that that's what I don't want
folks do know you're a few years into it
we're not just picking on you but I get
I had this call last hour another guy
one day you know work somewhere work as
a teacher 10 years and somewhere and be
underpaid so that he could get his
student loans forgiven and and you know
that it wasn't because he had a calling
to community service he was just trying
to get rid of student loans and so in
and so if I'm in your case I'm gonna go
make a hundred and a half almost
immediately moving towards 200 and get
this cleared up as fast as I can be
debt-free now back to your original
question there are two ways you can buy
a home a really really good credit score
which is going to require that you play
kissy-face with the bank a lot and you
pay everybody on time early and you have
a lot of debt and you pay her by on town
and early and you can if you just work
that and you pay them a lot of interest
over time you can build up a credit
score you probably have an excellent
credit score right now
yes sir yeah what is yours 800 just
under I'm at 799 yeah well you're
playing a lot of interest
I mean you pay on these student loans
you're paying on the car you've had the
credit cards for seven years you're
talked about that right
and so now you've worked real hard at
that you've given them a lot of money
for that score
so you can either maintain that score
and you get a house just they want to
think about they'll just throw money at
you for a house with a seven with a
seven eighty I mean they'll just give
you money and you know sign you up for
all kinds of wonderful things that you
don't need so or you can have a zero
credit score and you can qualify for a
home using what's called manual
underwriting now a debt free attorney
that makes a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars a year and has a zero credit
score has no trouble getting a home loan
okay yeah now some mortgage companies
are too stupid to know how to do that
but Churchill mortgage and others that
know how to do manual underwriting with
a zero credit score is that so I would
not worship at the altar of the great
FICO he is not your provider he's been
messing you over for years
and III instead would declare him a
false god
and run him off and that would mean that
I don't care what my credit score is as
a matter of fact my goal is to
systematically get rid of it
which the only way you have a zero
credit score is you've paid off every
single thing and you have zero zero
things reporting with a balance or open
account of any kind on your credit
report about six months later they will
declare you a non human a zero credit
score which was one of the greatest
honors of my life was um that they sent
me an email and they said uh we're so
confused did you die and I thought that
was maybe a threat but I wasn't sure
that you know they they they were really
worried if I ko that I had a to do that
my credit score was indeterminable
I must have died I'd be the only way
that you don't participate in this and
it's like man that makes me redneck
right there and if I want to get off the
grid completely but I definitely want to
get off the credit grid I'll just tell
you that because it's a treadmill so all
of that to say I know God go double my
income get these debts paid off as fast
as I could I wouldn't worry about my
credit score except to make sure that it
is systematically being destroyed down
to zero
and that would mean paying off those
credit cards and closing the accounts
because I your credit score will drop
when you do that and you've worked so
hard on yours it's gonna take your
breath away when it does that but you
have a goal of going to zero that's what
I would suggest you do and now we'll see
what you do whether you want to play
through or not but I sure wouldn't sure
wouldn't trade 800 thousand for 200 sure
wouldn't make that trade